papineau le comté ovi la deuxième plus
importante population multiethnique au
canada là l'héritage du passé assure
déjà des votes à justin trudeau to do is
for me to la jeunesse à peu on prend
vraiment les réelles de la société parce
que je sais tu retrouves d'après moyens
grands indices là d'un coup ne sont pas
très coûteux
le député sortant qui s'entraînent dans
ce centre de boxe du quartier saint
michel depuis six ans et quand même
encore loin d'avoir gagné son combat
le taux chômage y est raide à la
jeunesse sont les enjeux dont on discute
le plus ici c'est pas confiance à aucun
parti et les preuves que vous seriez pas
de changement au lieu de le dire que
c'est quand même beaucoup à mettre sur
les épaules de quelqu'un qui peut-être
un peu moins d'expérience que don que ça
veut dire que votre vote peut aller
ailleurs ailleurs pour bien des citoyens
pourraient être chez le npd fait sa
candidate anne lagacé dowson
un des arguments sur lesquels mais ses
partisans les rares présence de justin
trudeau dans son comté moi j'ai
franchement je ne connais pas je connais
de nom c'est tout
vous l'avez pas vu souvent n'ont de
toute façon j'ai besoin de lui je pense
qu'il est vraiment temps qu'on
débarrasse des conservateurs toutefois
pour tous je vois que madame lagarde
ancienne et très très présent dans le
quartier
ici ni le npd ni justin trudeau ne
devrait trop souffrir de leur position
plus ouverte sur le niqab est venu me
what do whatever inside section de
religion c'est la liberté pour ça si
tout le monde va faire son choix
mais on respecte la loi ça c'est correct
dans papineau la lutte s'annonce à 2 ici
jean sébastien cloutier radio canada
montréal